[Music]
[Music]
does it bother you that I'm not
completely human you were the most human
person I have ever met
[Music]
didn't I tell you to be home before dark
I just lost track of time
bleedin you have to be responsible
there's someone very special
hey kid not just a teenage girl hey
what's your problem you can't remember
what do you mean doc found you in the
scrap yard so you must be from up there
and I'm just an insignificant girl
that's what they want you to think
I'm not your daughter I don't know what
I am
I do yet the most advanced weapon ever
but that's just a shell it's not bad or
good that part's up to you
I do not stand by
the presence of evil
she's threatening the natural order of
things
tonight is not a game
is a heart
I need you to destroy the girl called
Aleta
you'd be the biggest mistake of your
life
and what's that
under estimating Who I am
[Applause]
[Music]
once everything was awesome
now everything is okay Lucy I brought
you coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark times oh my gosh Ness
did I interrupt you brooding just now
times have changed
you need to change with them we have to
be tough and battle-ready
Oh
hurry the door is slowly closing
oh hey it's Jane so cold
see that wasn't so bad nothing got in
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't get it rescue my friends get out
of there i'm mcqueen whatever I would
not be I'm getting super evil vibes here
I could change my form to something else
if this makes you uncomfortable
hey guys he'll go back don't worst was
much more palatable double dot on your
face
now
who are you I'm your worst nightmare Oh
me when I'm late to school and I forgot
my homework and my pants are made of
pudding
no I don't
it's just a movie you see Natalie knots
not a fairytale girls like us don't get
that oh why look in the mirror doll when
though Julia Roberts
every day day swipe my father loved me
Nataly saying that romantic comedies are
about all those maybes Eliza - terrible
pop songs I think people would have an
easier time seeing you if you were a
little more open you're in your mercy
sir this isn't an emergency room this is
at williams-sonoma them away downtown it
looks like somebody's what a beauty
filter across New York City and I win
one what's your emergency
someone's broken into my apartment and
they've taken everything and replace a
little bit much nicer stuff so your
emergency is that your apartment is too
big and you have every shoe you could
ever want yeah exactly that's what I
yeah you go crazy I hit my head really
hard and I woke up in this alternate
universe and now I have a gay sidekick
who's setting gay-rights back like 100
years of love working the legs and guys
look at me in the eyes you're caught
beguiling aren't you are you feeling
what I'm feeling
No
I'm trapped enough
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm pay boots what's the update I have
to get a man to fall in love with me
yeah I'm Josh he's such a beautiful me
good morning beautiful last night was
amazing I didn't think we actually did
anything it just cut to the next morning
what just get back here okay last night
was amazing
Natalie I love
[Music]
so happy adjure here after my parents
died and I didn't really think I was
gonna be able to come back to Tijuana
but you always made me feel like family
you are my family
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Eric Thomas Angela I just wanna find
my friend I need you to do a favor for
me first
you mess around and I'll kill you both
depart the car real close to the curb
is is you you have to believe me they
made me do it the building that you blew
up the DEA safe house you know how long
you go away for unless you help us you
know Esparza
see the
forget your friends no one's coming to
see you whether or not you survive
it's entirely up to you
you gotta learn how to use one of these
a viola bullet
balleseros everything
ever since you showed up the police in
one step
you better do what you need to do Toledo
has a mole in his operation plan gonna
come
I'm not giving up on my family Lila
the bullet settles everything
[Music]
I'm very honored to be named keyhole of
Citizen of the Year I'm just a guy who
keeps strip of civilization open when
you drive to see though day after day is
easy to think about the road not taken I
was lucky I picked a good road early and
the state on mister cocksman what can I
do for it it's about your son
[Music]
died of a heroin overdose we had no Hans
Kyle wasn't my druggie sorry but all the
parents say that you're gonna have to
say a few words
Kyle's dip tell me what happened you got
mixed up with some drug dealer fight
game you like certain people put this
with all these nicknames speedo Viking
Eskimo it's a gangster thing did you
have a nickname wingman wait am I gonna
kill him
no guys one guy could disappear too who
wants me dead
three of Vikings drug dealers who
disappeared what makes you think you can
kill a man no better crime novel
what are you doing
job
this doesn't happen in kia it just did
Nell's cocksman citizen to the year good
for him
[Music]
critique is so limiting and emotionally
draining I hope you find something to
explain what's happening which one's
better one
oh it's do better worse no different no
different I am quite curious to know II
think I think sober hasn't been good for
him Pierce was in the full bloom of
alcoholism ear exactly never should have
quit drinking no originality no courage
I mean I can't save you and you just
took them you have no friends
I can make you rich brilliant demand has
people ready to kill good as an artist
and vengeful diesels we have everyone
they all just used blood to create the
reddish block
you ever notice anything about this
painting look at it long enough a moose
as I research these I'm starting to
think there's a disgust for the world of
money who spent decades in a psychiatric
hospital for the criminally insane
there is some sort of power
some spirits
it's connected to his art something
truly goddamn strange is going on this
is a slaughterhouse are you aware that
desaster dollars aren't be destroyed
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we did it
I can't save you
[Music]
people thought she was partially severe
we're trending on Instagram it's a major
hit
[Music]